aquí tengo una pregunta del examen apec
al cluj ave del 2015 y me dicen
considera la curva dada por la ecuación
que tengo aquí se puede mostrar que la
primera derivada con respecto a x es
esta expresión que tengo aquí así que
muy bien
despejaron la derivada para nosotros y
aquí tenemos el inciso sem para realizar
este vídeo me he saltado el inciso a y
el b y el inciso se dice evaluar la
segunda derivada de y con respecto a x
en el punto de la curva donde x es igual
a menos 1 y que es igual a 1
pausa el vídeo y ps puedes encontrar la
respuesta bien ahora vamos a trabajarlo
juntos primero déjame escribir la
derivada acá abajo
tengo que la derivada de ye con respecto
a x es igual a entre 3 y el cuadrado
menos x ahora a nosotros nos interesa la
segunda derivada entonces tendremos que
calcular la derivada con respecto a x de
ambos lados así que vamos a hacerlo
vamos a tomar el operador derivada de
ambos lados bien en el lado izquierdo
vamos a obtener la segunda derivada de
que con respecto a x bien y ahora que
obtendremos en el lado derecho bueno hay
varias formas de encontrar esta derivada
sin embargo creo que usar la regla del
cociente es la mejor forma de
encontrarla a veces me quejo de que la
regla del cociente es simplemente una
variación de la regla del producto pero
en estos casos
así que recordemos que esta derivada
será la derivada del numerador con
respecto a x lo cual es simplemente la
derivada de ye gon respecto x esto que
multiplica al denominador entonces esto
que multiplica a 3 cuadrada menos x y
esto - y ahora tenemos que tomarnos el
numerador tal cual está ya esto
multiplicarlo por la derivada con
respecto a x del denominador ahora cuál
es la derivada de este denominador con
respecto a x bueno la derivada de 3
cuadrada con respecto a x es lo mismo
que la derivada de 3 y cuadrada con
respecto ayer lo cual es simplemente 6
que observan solamente estoy usando la
regla de la potencia ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de que con
respecto a x es decir
derivada de james con respecto a x
por ahora solo he tomado la derivada de
esta primera parte con respecto a x que
es la derivada de 3 cuadrada con
respecto ayer por la derivada de ye con
respecto a x solo aplique la regla de la
cadena ya esto hay que quitarle la
derivada de x con respecto a x lo cual
es simplemente 1
ya todo esto tengo que dividirlo entre
el denominador elevado al cuadrado
recuerda hasta aquí apenas estamos en la
mitad de la regla del cociente ahora hay
que dividir todo esto entre el
denominador elevado al cuadrado es decir
310 cuadrada
- x esto elevado al cuadrado
ahora para nuestra suerte nos piden que
evaluemos todo esto en un punto en el
punto de la curva donde x es igual a
menos 1 y que es igual a 1 para nuestra
suerte nos piden que evaluemos todo esto
en un punto en lugar de tener que hacer
un montón de simplificación algebraica
así que podemos decir que cuando x es
igual a menos 1 y que es igual a 1
déjame escribirlo cuando x es igual a
menos 1 y que es igual a 1 primero
cuánto vale la derivada de ye con
respecto a x en ese punto y bueno tengo
ayer pero llévale 1
entonces me queda uno dividido entre 3
porque al cuadrado pero vale 1 entonces
me quedara 3 x 1 elevado al cuadrado lo
cual es 1
y bueno tengo a x pero x vale menos 11
negativo entonces me va a quedar más 1
es decir esto va a ser lo mismo que un
cuarto
ok ahora necesito saber cuánto vale la
segunda derivada de g con respecto a x
bueno pues esto va a ser según lo que
acabamos de encontrar y primero tengo a
la derivada de que con respecto a x lo
cual acabamos de ver a cávaco que cuando
x escuela menos 1 y llegó a la 1 me da
un cuarto entonces tengo un cuarto que
va a multiplicar a 3 y cuadrada menos x
bueno es 3 por 1 elevado al cuadrado
esto es 3 - menos uno menos uno negativo
lo cual es más 1 entonces todo esto de
aquí me va a dar 4 ok ya esto le tenemos
que en restar bien pero que vale 1 así
que simplemente pondré mi signo negativo
que multiplica
y bueno ahora tengo esta parte de aquí 6
bien que multiplica a la derivada de ye
con respecto a x menos uno bueno me
quedan seis por uno por un cuarto es
decir 6 por 1 4 ok y esto menos 1
bien todo esto hay que dividirlo entre y
tengo tres que cuadrada menos x
bueno es 3 por 1 al cuadrado lo cual es
3 - menos 1 es decir más 13 + 1 es 4 al
cuadrado lo cual me da 16 ahora cuánto
será todo esto vamos a simplificar un
poco esto me va a quedar un 4x4 eso es
simplemente uno y aquí tengo seis por un
cuarto eso es lo mismo que un entero un
medio menos uno bueno todo esto de aquí
es simplemente un medio y entonces uno
menos un medio eso me va a dar un medio
entre 16 y ahora si necesitamos un
pequeño redoble de tambor porque esto va
a ser igual a 1 entre 30 y
y ya está con esto hemos terminado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo